is an Emmy award-winning actor of
multiple times and he is the author of
this new book called spirit of the horse
he is none other than right here in the
flesh William Shatner good to see you
sir thank you so much you can see in
that picture you with heart uh how the
horse is leaning in and if you were to
analyze the picture my attitude the
horses attitude
there's communion mm-hmm you see the
communion between the two yes and that's
the spirit of the horse and so when when
was the first time you ever got on a
horse well I got on a horse when I was
12 years old I was in Montreal where I
was growing up and there was a rental
stable and I'd never been on our sport
and I've forgotten how I was able to
afford I think I was swapping out
swapping out stables and they put me on
a horse and I galloped around and I
remember I'm a mother saying how did you
do that I said I didn't know I had an
Infiniti from a very early age but it's
expensive and I wasn't in the in the
category of of that expense a tick until
I was middle-aged and had some money to
buy a horse that I really got involved
and that's the story of the beginning of
me and horses yeah and then you know do
you ever think about owning racing
horses or anything like well I'm
interested in all horses the horse
itself is a magical creature for me what
I'm what I've come to his quarter horses
here in in California and in particular
reining horses and if you're interested
I'll explain that and then I have a
place in Lexington and I'm into show
horses American Saddlebreds and american
standardbred trotting horses and I've
won World Championships and the in those
things and saddles and blue ribbons and
all kinds of awards and rayner's William
Shatner here on the Rich Eisen show
against spirit of the war
is his new book you need to go check it
out in bookstores near you as well as on
online
what would you what's your favorite
sports team which which team have you
been a spectator of or you you watch
most William C I'm how old are you I'm
47 years ago kid he's just young you're
in the prime of your life behind your
desk with your ass spreading out but yes
it's a it's all okay no well it's on a
daily basis we gotta watch but when
you're my age you're you follow people
who are older like Peyton Manning okay
say so wherever Peyton went my web since
Los Angeles didn't have a team and I
couldn't identify and I stayed angry at
the Rams and Oakland the Raiders I had a
hate on for them for having less Pacific
we can't have that
No so now 20 years goes by and we don't
have a team and we're and I have Monday
Night Football at my place and 20 people
come up I mean we really celebrate the
football C's okay so Peyton became my
hero and now he's retired now he's
retired so what am I going to do and now
the Rams are here and they have to to be
fair they have to generate sympathy and
empathy mm-hmm and they haven't from the
sports fan here in Los Angeles then
we've been orphans have you ever been to
a Super Bowl you ever done whatever but
no I I have been okay years ago but
mostly Super Bowl at my house so what is
it what is this Super Bowl what is this
Super Bowl at your house at well I shot
an 11-foot screen 11 feet yeah diagonal
the room was built around the projection
of 11-foot screen yes so that the
support timbers and beams and things
like that in front you know where the
ceiling is supported is wide enough to
support the to show the on the wall
right the screen this projection so we
have a room devoted to that screen and
an ax counter
we're a lot of food and beer and stuff
like that is okay right so maybe 30 40
50 people are in the room screaming on
Super Bowl mmm it's right right to do
that then go to a stadium so are you a
beer drinker a wine drinker which one
would you say so that's what you're
serving and yeah right nothing hard
because I have a long driveway and if
you're okay
really up against it we'll roll down the
driving aggregate or horseback tink you
take but for zebra to go down on a
horseback down there you need special
shoes because of this I breathe as well
now so um how did you get involved with
Star Trek William when did you get
involved yeah why did that first get
started for you in your the the the
iconic story goes like this
they made a pilot of Star Trek with
another actor and NBC didn't want to buy
it but they were sufficiently enthralled
by this concept but they wanted to try
again and I was in New York doing
something or other and my phone rings
and it's gene Roddenberry who wants me
to come and see that pilot but the idea
of playing the captain so I went and saw
the pilot I thought it was terrific
lacked a few things that I made some
suggestions and and and and then we were
shot another pilot and it sold and we
did three seasons of it did you have any
a sense at the time
what it might be what we're I'm asked
that and and and it's like really like
the Rich Eisen show is really great
thank you so fifty years from now people
are going to point to it and say now
that is how you finish a radio show and
a TV combined pretty TD T V and radio
radio and TV TV live rich solve the
problem yes 50 years from now does that
sound outlandish hmm let me think about
that let me tell you my point of view
yes it sounds outlandish
well because there is an iron-rich and
Isaac Lee you know I mean I'm sometimes
get caught up in myself a little bit
well everybody does but you can't afford
to do that on the air so you had no idea
at the time essentially oh my god it was
who fake hassle in three years oh that's
another gig wonder what's next
so then when did you realize that this
was about another life fix years later
they started showing the outtakes where
we had played the buffoon well when I
say we I mean I joking around on the set
yes and they were filming and the
editors put together a a Christmas show
of all they out take that so there were
two Christmases in three seasons so we
had 20 minutes were of a gag reel six
years after it was canceled I hear that
the gag reels being played in in bar I
was up at Mammoth as a matter of fact
skiing and and some bar in Mammoth was
playing the Gangrel what the heck is
that
mm-hm and I'm that's when you realize so
I thought why would they do that I
wonder what's happening then they were
calls and we're going to do a movie and
we're not going to do a movie we're
gonna do a series earlier so be there
was what happened was Star Wars is what
happened
Star Wars gave new life well our Trekkie
there were shots fired people killing
themselves in Paramount over with Star
Wars I said well what have we got well
does this show that was canceled and
maybe and the guy and his name is
Roddenberry would he do it no I'm not
gonna do it yes you're going to do I did
a whole documentary on on the story I'm
telling you no kidding yeah so well you
know I'm William Shatner here because
you know there's there are arguments
amongst pop culture people as to which
is the better and we'll know argument
okay and the argument is Star Trek I'm a
guest on your I know and I'm talking but
no I know no but that that is that that
is something that people go back and
forth as to what's real about the
science fiction genre or not yeah and so
you know in the argument the argument is
Star Wars was so technically proficient
you know there was great effects and
stuff like that they were they were the
leaders and ILM was them and we you know
there would be somebody like below
pushing a spaceship on the string some
guy like me yeah that's good we'll do it
yeah but the stories were good well I
mean look I got to tell you uh the Rafic
on Star Trek 2 was a phenomenal movie in
its own right a phenomenal movie I want
art to finish because you were viewer
you were um you were honest to the
original as well as advancing it and
also you know the way that uh that the
Star Trek characters had become of a
certain age and that was part of the
conversation well I thought it was
phenomenal one of I'm delighted thank
you so no you you know they're going to
do is showing somewhere along the line
of the Wrath of Khan in theaters yes the
Chosin says I don't know when they're
going to do it but well I would be
that'd be something I would say for sure
William Shatner here on the Rich Eisen
show and when you screamed Khan was that
was that your own interpretation of the
lie I think so I remember I scream a lot
do you realize I'll take this any day of
the week back William Shatner here on
the show so again you also had an
incredible run with the David Kelly
programs as well bus and yet with Boston
Legal when did you first get involved
with with David Kelly well that you
invited me to breakfast and said I've
written this shown on this role and
there's a I do a one-man show and which
I play the scene in which I'm talking
about he said you know the guys a little
a little senile yes and I said I can
play that yeah then just the the role of
Denny Crane was born then I've been in
there I guess so
so again you've never
you've been it was Super Bowl would you
ever tried hockey did you ever try
walking up in Canada hockey hockey is
the national sport in Canada I guess a
red-blooded although my blood is
somewhat thinner no Canadian so hockey
should be like natural but it wasn't I
went to skiing so I skied for my school
so you did the scheme I did skiing I was
a pretty good scared one is that right
downhill slalom what are ya
Oh jumping Jiminy's no no not jumping I
never jumped I did jump on horses
till somebody said you know you can get
really hurt
jumping because a horse will invariably
refuse to go and and are my friend
Superman Christopher Reeve with
Christopher Reeve actually died because
of it yes iPhone six months afterwards
after his accident
I kept thinking every time I put my foot
the stirrup I kept thinking I wonder if
that's going to happen to me today well
took a long time for it to go well I've
actually this is right here in this book
your love of horses spirit spirit of the
horse right here on the show we got the
book right here and you can get it
online you can also go into bookstores
and get it what's the one role that you
you wish you could have done that you
did I don't think that way rich I don't
I don't know I'm sure you know people
said should we get I'm trying to think
of a name actor or Shatner they got the
name actor come on now wave no III don't
think of that but I just finished a film
that I really think it's going to be
good
called senior moment just literally a
couple of days ago finished filming it I
think it'll be terrific
I got this horse show that I put on
every year for the last 30 years called
if you'll forgive me the priceline.com
Hollywood charity or show sponsored by
Wells Fargo
and I had to because every dollar that
we get for this charity goes to kids and
goes to veterans sure helped a lot of
hypnotherapy writing for therapeutic
programs which is part of the mystique
of the spirit of the horse that horses
for some reason can help people
physically emotionally and have done so
I've seen miracles I've seen kids walk
with never walk shouldn't be walking
kids who talk would never talk I've seen
I've seen veterans come out of their
shell to come out of that thousand-yard
stare mmm and communicate I've talked to
autistic kids
I talked to autistic kids who've done
the writing therapeutic programs
something about a horse that I talked
about the spirit the soul the heart of
the horse and how I evolve from being a
mechanical rider oh so much on the bit
as you both collect the horse got to
getting inside the horse's head so that
there is a communication between a rider
and and and and horse to the point where
I have improved my ability as a horseman
every year since I started riding up
until right now tomorrow I'm going to
get on a horse I'll be a better rider
for the sense of being inside the horse
and saying good morning I'm with you I'm
here I've got you collected now let's go
over here and he's just known I guess
yeah and we're talking nonverbal
interspecies conversation I have it all
the time well it's a wonderful book
spirit of the horse William Shatner you
are gem thank you for coming on this I
greatly greatly appreciate you coming
thank you the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy